former Santa
beautiful voice musician sting composed
the theme song for a new show in Rome
that's bringing history to life the
production uses special effects to
transform how people experience
Michelangelo's Sistine Chapel
masterpiece a director who's designed
Olympic ceremonies created the show with
the Vatican's permission of course
Seth Doane when the lucky ones got a
ticket and takes us behind the scenes
he's in Rome near the Sistine Chapel
death good morning take a look at this
view of st. Peter's Basilica and behind
it the Sistine Chapel about six million
people visit the Sistine Chapel every
year and now just down the road at a
theater it is possible to see in a way
it has never been seen before lasers
lights and a thunderous sound system
a distinctly modern dimension to a story
that's roughly 500 years old
Michelangelo painting the Sistine Chapel
images filled the theater it's an
immersive experience that even its
creative director
Marco valach as a hard time describing
it's easier to say what is now there is
ballet but is not a ballet there is a
lot of beautiful music by John Metcalf
and sting but it's not a musical it's a
very technological show ballets treated
Michelangelo as a sort of superhero
whose frescoes in digital form turned
Rome's former Symphony Hall into a
second Sistine Chapel what did you think
because independence it is spectacular
[Music]
usually we do a one-off so we is a hey
tiger soon and he's finished and it's
gone this this time it keeps going I
open up the door to the fake Sistine job
ouch lettuce peak backstage to see how
the show works what the cast wears and
how he took inspiration from spectacles
the Catholic Church has staged this is
the coffin of john paul ii which for to
me which I love ceremonies that was one
of the best ceremony ever done belch
takes images that visitors strained to
see in real life and expands and
animates them he pushed to create this
production and got the blessing of the
Vatican
that one skeptical Italian columnist
wasn't so nice calling all of the
special effects visual viagra when you
hear critics say this is just too much
it's all show they told me every time
they said oh but it's like Disney and I
said but Disney well Disney is a genius
what's wrong with it Marco told us he
finds inspiration from of all places
rides at theme parks which he says are
particularly immersive experiences for
audiences and he says he knows he's done
a good job when he looks around an
audience and doesn't see people on their
cell phones nor the full attention of
everyone my favorite quote of the day
that is ballet but he's not a ballet
listen I don't know Italian but we do
know bellissimo all right Seth Doane
thank you as always